Sean before we even get to the Warriors
or Kobe I know there's a lot of jostling
going around four playoff seedings and
there's one spot left tell me why I
should care you know this is when my NBA
fandom really kicks in seems to me like
there's four or five teams that have a
legit shot at this thing should I care
about who the three seed or four seed is
in the eastern conference or who gets in
in the Western Conference well I don't
think you should care about the three
and a four seed in the East those teams
Atlanta Miami bosque and Charlotte
they're pretty much even in terms of
talent how they match up in the first
round I don't think it's going to make a
big difference one way or the other in
the east and how that shakes out but in
the West you know look Houston's head I
mean but what a year I mean losing Kevin
McHale ty lawson didn't work out you
know basically for a team that reached
the western conference finals last year
and had an MVP contender and hardened is
just a disaster year but they still have
a shot they win they're in and to see
them play the Warriors and look I'm sure
will be a sweet but at least they've
salvaged what was really a really bad
season yeah I mean but do they salvaged
it just by making the playoffs and
losing the Warriors I mean they at least
get back to the postseason I mean I
think it's a really big deal for them to
say the little face I still think
there's probably going to be major
changes any off see it in the offseason
I'm not so sure Dwight Howard comes back
I would be surprised if he doesn't come
back then what are you going to do with
that team you're going to have to pretty
much reinvent that team what about Daryl
Morey cuz he returned this general
manager there's still going to be
questions but at least they give
themselves you know some life some you
know face-saving gesture by getting back
to the playoffs and playing the Warriors
again talk with Sean Powell there's a
really nice job for nba.com here on the
Dan Patrick show you
mention the Warriors Sean how big is
this record to you may I think we can
debate how much regular season records
really matter how much does it matter to
you well you know I was around to see
the Bulls get there 72 wins and I see
the two teams simmer in this suspect
number one they were very very tough to
be obviously you know in that many games
but they also had a rock star
surrounding I mean Steph Curry draymond
Green klay Thompson I mean these guys
are now the face of the NBA used to be
LeBron James and Dwyane Wade and Chris
Bosh but that's changed that's clipped
the wars or must-see TV they're
entertaining they're bringing in the
casual basketball fan a lot of fun to
watch very positive for the NBA all
around and they're pretty much an
enjoyable bunch starting with you know
Steve Kerr on down so I think that's all
good I mean what it means i mean i don't
know i think we can't answer that
question until after the NBA Finals if
they win the championship then yeah it's
a big deal but getting that record and
not getting the championship then I
think it's sort of a more of a hollow
feeling so give me give me a percentage
chance in your mind that the Golden
State Warriors repeat that they win it I
mean are we talking fifty percent chance
or in your mind or ninety percent chance
that they win it all again and if they
don't who beats them well we're off I
think it's probably their championship
to lose of course i was watching the
masters not solved you know speed but
after the what 8th 9th hole and I
thought the determinant was his to lose
and obviously lost it but can you
imagine being this team four times in a
seven-game series you know that's very
tough to imagine I mean right now in the
West you know the team's trying to
prevent the warriors from getting to the
NBA Finals I think you have to narrow it
down maybe to disperse and Oklahoma City
Thunder we don't know what the Clippers
will look like when Blake Griffin gets
back but even with Blake they haven't
been able to handle the
for years so I mean those are the only
two teams that can really trip them up
the Warriors are pretty deep also Ross
you got understand that steph curry
doesn't have to play 40 minutes a game
like Jordan had to play 40 minutes a
game for steph curry doesn't have to do
that because they're deep well coached
they pass the ball they play well look
I'm not telling you anything you haven't
seen and then when you look in the East
who can stop the Warriors other than the
Cavaliers I know Toronto's play them
very well this season but it's just the
regular season and Toronto may not even
get out of these the one factor is this
you know last year Cleveland didn't have
Kyrie Irving for the most part didn't
have kevin love an eight and they were
up to one on the Warriors and so people
would say well you know those guys are
healthy they're going to play a more
competitive series but of course LeBron
James had to play out of his mind but
then they get up to one I just think
right now it's the Warriors to lose I
think you know based on what we've seen
in a regular season and what we know
this team is capable know what's up
doing in the postseason I'd be very
surprised if they didn't get a
championship yeah I think it's a good
point John I was watching them sunday
night I couldn't believe how long Kerr
kept Steph Curry out and they extended
their lead when curry was out which it's
just it's frankly amazing i love them i
hope they beat the records and tomorrow
night i think that they will and even
though I'm 37 Shawn I grew up you know
with the Bulls I'm frankly tired of
hearing guys from that era act like they
would kill the Warriors they'd sweep
them it wouldn't even be close do you
buy that argument whatsoever well you
know Roz that's the ultimate top radio
watercooler discussion about a scenario
that will never see you know people will
say that you know with it but the rule
changes you know you can't hand check
Steph Curry and so therefore he's going
to go out like if that's the case then
you couldn't hand check Michael Jordan
how many points with Michael Jordan
average in that series I was lucky
enough to see the Jordan I mean Jordan
and the Bulls at their height all six
championships and now i'm watching the
Warriors
I think it would be very interesting
very interesting series but anything
that I say what difference is a bit
we're not going to see it I can tell you
this if the war is where to play the
bull right now they probably them
because Michael Jordan's over 50 and if
the Bulls are played a warrior's back
then they probably know Steph Curry was
only seven and really that's really
that's the only that you can really look
at you really look at it and get an
accurate you know assessment of the
situation yeah I just don't remember
team shooting and passing like the
Warriors do I i love i'm with you i
think they should be on national TV
every single game next year and i'm not
kidding i do want to ask you Sean one
question about Kobe Bryant so this might
not be that popular but I think it's a
legitimate question to ask he's
obviously one of the best players of all
time fantastic career but when we're
sizing up Kobe against a guy like magic
Johnson or Michael Jordan or LeBron
James maybe someday or maybe even Steph
Curry how much credit do you give Kobe
for the three titles he won with Shaq in
other words I know that all these guys
had a good player with them but Michael
Jordan was still the best player on
those Bulls teams and Magic Johnson was
still the best players on the Lakers
team and LeBron etc etc whereas as good
as Kobe was and is he i do not think he
was the best player on those first three
lakers team so does he get the same
credit for those championships even
though he wasn't really the alpha male
those years yeah i think you have to
give him some credit look Shaq was the
best player that Team Shaq was the face
of the franchise not obviously not even
coming close to winning without shaq but
i think we saw a growth in Kobe those
three years here's a guy who you know he
had all those air balls against the
Golden State other Utah Jazz and Game
five of the 97 West Conference Finals
and he grew up a lot from there to the
point where even Shack and I think after
the second championship said kobe is the
best player in the game you know you saw
a guy go from he was 17 years old when
he was drafted to pretty quickly
becoming a
a-list star in about three or four years
i do i would i would agree with you this
i think what we saw from kobe after
shack and during pile gasol was much
more impressive than what we saw from
Kobe with Shaq because he became a
singular star without him you know we
saw the MVP the scoring titles and then
with Pau Gasol I thought he went to the
final three times and anyone two of them
I thought he had a less impressive team
then then he had with Shaq and he showed
us you know the famous competitive air
that the you know the grit desire all
the things that make him a basketball
icon now we saw that and he's had a
great career I mean make no mistake
about it yeah it's crazy they were
showing video from when he was younger I
almost forgot Sean how athletic he was
how explosive he was you know it's been
such a long time since he was that kind
of player the injuries and everything
just some of the dunks he had absolutely
incredible Sean really appreciate the
time and you hop on the board hey time
up there he is Sean pal nba.com good
stuff the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience